e em lobbies culpa que a concorrência
mas aqui é vesgo e da calcinha rapaz
morador mix pode usar a verba
[Música]
e aí agora que a sede do canal starz
todos os bens com vocês mulher tom k eu
fico louco quem vai ficar parecendo um
pouco do morro do borel eles a xata tudo
tranquilo ele acha não vai ter carro
aqui que eu sou profissional eu sou seu
em cana doa eu to the show cara chega
agora de manhã em belém foi bem muito
obrigado galera do pará sensacional kahn
deve parar e estacionar humanas pessoal
legal demais foi só falar assim o
intenso no nicho assistir o canal já que
quando era pequenininha um tira uma foto
com a minha filha um beijo pará inteiro
que eu amo esse próxima semana eu tô em
minas gerais o babete dia 29 e 30 em
sete lagoas sedia o primeiro toy montes
claros agora vai ter mais claro certeza
absoluta em seu ingresso pode fazer o
meu show para o paroxismo top ingressos
aqui neste site a mensagem que você sabe
esses dias eu dei conta que era de
verdade eu me dei conta disso que eu sou
um cara eu sou bobo eu sou bucal sentido
isso se tem um canal gigantes e faz
piadas não tem como ser burro burro e se
desligou do fundo eu tô falando bhutto
sentir assim seu mundo precisar de mim
para evoluírem está a mesma merda
jurássica em que as coisas se esticou e
não é da minha cabeça não consigo
entender mc vaz tecnologia no mundo que
puxa a pessoa criou falar eu olho se eu
falo eu não criaria infelizmente isso
aqui é impossível pra mim criar ou a
caneta a caneta é [__] caneta é esse
choque a caneta aqui tá ligado a iac é
uma bolinha aqui dentro é aqui é a tinta
tinta 10 faça pela bolinha quanto a uma
medida que você escreve a tinta fica é
mó sensacional a galera de ver pegar
quando ele falou assim o uol o comité
toca de show que ele fez pra cá tu lá
que até proparoxítona canerday você está
do outro lado até você pensa assim a oim
diz mais diz hug besteira eu já entendi
o funcionamento da câmera desde que eu
me entendo por gente claro que já
inventaram o planeta não é fácil você
entender o funcionamento da cana entenda
caneta agora eu não conseguiria criar
animais teve alguém um dia em algum
lugar que falou assim time ninguém
achei que desgraça toli gado aí tive que
pegar alguma coisa que vão até chegar a
essa caneta que tope por ter passado
muitas caneta horrível tampa potã pela
tecnologia que é uma coisa você tem uma
tigela adentrar músicas e bota coisa em
cima leon panetta um tampo agora tampa
que roda se encaixe não sai eu nunca
pensar no negócio de sica que alguém um
dia pensou nisso ela falou assim aumenta
precisamos derrotar a al-qaeda chegou
bem botou um negócio em cima todo mundo
aí o cara virou a vasilha
caiu tudo eita [__] aí veio outro
pensou ah ah ah sim faz o eu criei seus
roubado olha só e não cai galera ó
bruxaria bruxaria fogo do poder e e
tocava fogo no cara que a ciência é
evoluísse o espelho anão não espelha é
[__] o espelho é o que eu digo bicho é
muito fácil hoje a gente olha para o
espelho falar do meu dentro de casa tem
respeitou um lugar meio de roupas sempre
vai ter um espelho quebrado e pega um
carro esperando aí eu e mais alguém
inventou aquela povo tava lá se ipi olha
olha aí eu não é apenas o fato do sind
aéreas índia é muito besta que trocando
as coisas tese do brasil por espelho ou
eu troco um irmão meu ombro espelho
troféu brasil o espelho é [__] é um
vidro você olha nele tá você laís
marcinho amor do cara quer você mexe faz
assim a mexeu a mão daquele estranho
horrível que você está vendo a onde mais
esperança faz o gol
anton vidro com a mala já que botou
camada é fácil saber o que é que é um
espelho sempre que você já sabe como é
que faz agora alguém criou aquela merda
agora eu não tenho capacidade de criar
um espelho eu sou bobo eu nuclear e nada
há pessoal falou em se tu fosse o dono
do mundo como é que as pessoas fazem
passíveis de pacientes a galera lagoa
ali veio todo mundo ninguém joga pedra
chave ficar bem quietinho lá ansiosos
rapidinho pronto sai deixa os outros e
nada melhor que eu não tenho capacidade
de criar inventar um espelho agora
alguém falou e atacará nem liguei é isso
é pegar o rebote
o negócio ficou kilda e o avião a apa
[__] que pariu ali é [__] o avião não
fica indignado o avião ficou indignado
ele do avião que o avião vai assim que
nunca eles começam a subir a fecomércio
decolava do tempo de são vendelino tem
condição do a porta dessa forma é muito
grande isso aqui cabe à mas a turbina
que turbina negócio levanta um negócio
daquele tamanho não mas os físicos
disseram que a força que força de quem é
irmão também tomando esse avião cara no
tempo de são caras você vê a zaga
fazendo assim eu tenho um negócio fácil
saber só um pouquinho mais vulnerável
mas o bicho era um negocinho andando
peixe
ei não não tem condição caso não tem a
ver eu vejo aquele técnico zinho na
telinha deputada imagem
agora quando vejo esses avião que cruza
o oceano dona do meu de noé eu prefiro
nem pensar quando eu tô vendo avião seu
comércio pensar muito bom avião começa a
mudar o campo sabendo isso logo que tem
condição é uma coisa muito eu acho que o
avião é uma coisa que deus deixou fox é
tanta gente tentando voar fazendo avião
e voar e caí que brava e se arrombava e
agora vou me explicar o clube joga ali
por morrer também
ô lá em paris fez uma roupa botou aqui
dizer que agora eu vou pular o arrolou s
arrebentou no chão ficou parecendo um
meio que sheyla chegou aqui dentro disse
assim vai vovô pelo amor não aguento
mais ver gente morrendo eu vou deixar
vai aí falam mas marwijk é muito fácil
saber de rochas são duas turbinas muito
grandes o combustível fica distribuído
entre as duas asas para haver um
equilíbrio na turbina muito potente leva
esse avião direcionamento dos flex vai
pra cima vai para baixo na hora de
pousar
ora só muito fácil é só botar o avião
inclinado b pra cima primeiras rodas
traseiras depois a dianteira aciona os
reveses a torcida vai começar a rodar o
contrário vai frear o avião vai parar
muito fácil lógico depois que já tá
feito depois que alguém já inventou já
construiu é muito fácil saber agora eu
não construiria um avião impossível se a
humanidade depender de mim para se
locomover
tava todo mundo bomba a a mulher da
carroça ou portem o senhor por favor
o facebook da sanção não pode tratar
disso pelo citar o pênis só lendo por
favor mande banda você nem está usando o
caso está apropriado maldita hoje que
deixei camponeses e regência carrocinha
pra mim não dava para deixar seu lugar é
fácil só saio daqui quando você
construir um negócio que você podia
voltar lá 40 anos depois eu ia tá lá
está
não não e que também passa o negócio é
baratinho mas alguém se propôs a fazer
até conseguir que um diz que foram os
gêmeos lá de paris quem foi por nenhum
que foi só tomou toda vez que alguém
entra nessa discussão de quem foi que
inventou o avião pra mim eu comece a
discutir qual o velho império capanna
fons gêmeos da de paris que fizer é
conversa passei nenhum df foi santos
dumont lá pegou um negócio 14 quatorze
bis botton em cima do outro fez 14 bis
no meu amigo já vi na história o rapaz
que fez é 2gb tese em pane o rapaz e
está treinando agora pareça redondo foi
um negócio de avião a fazer quadro e
bolo som e wifi a não aí ainda não
acabou para mim acabou acabou sentindo a
inteligência pra mim mas foi acabou
caramba o tempo isso se comunicar à
distância eles é muito fácil é trote a
pessoa não escutar o grid mas não hajam
cela na desgraça um evento mais faytouni
você mexe no ar tem nada que nada
simplesmente um guarda roupa alguma
coisa uma câmera já o cara vai falar e
falar com a gente o caso de sean está ok
fai aqui aí sim bota thala boto a senha
se não entra no seu só que no seu é que
tem um número sims é à la [__] que pariu
bom e só se tiver no final se não tiver
um sinal num capta no entanto é um
negócio que está no ar mas só se você
viu aqui por exemplo no quarto eu gravo
pega e foi aqui no peru em fahel é uma
obra aqui falou em low ammiano não
caminha não está dormindo
é a luta magazine luiza amarga luta é um
canal que resolve com de tecnologias a
essas coisas de bicho smartphone
tvs março tvs na hora que rasgou na hora
pelo me ajuda que eu estou precisando de
ajuda que não vai aqui o roteador ficar
na sala e aqui no quartel fica meio
assim chumbrego assim 111 festa não esse
aqui não tem como espalhar não o sinal
mais para o prédio todo pausa na piscina
com todo lugar eu já mandei já ouviu
áudio shine a favela ea foto tema
barulho que eu sair agora respondeu
responder que estava no al também oie
inversão claro é superfácil deixe sempre
mais alta possível e longe de objetos
metálicos e isso causa interferência não
é esse o meu irmão cara eu não criaria
wifi impossível para mim é impossível
pessoas já provou isso é preciso trocar
informações com vocês que se de um modo
falar em casa amanhã 6 horas de conversa
não preciso um tempo real ao vivo de um
se você vier vou estar vivo que estão
mais um conforto eu aqui em caso de gol
então na sua casa meu amigo meu deus mas
criar agora não teve um filho da [__] um
cara que ele falou assim não vou fazer
vai vai vou criar meta acabando a
batalha pelo gravando o álbum daqui me
ajuda meu nome mas não ajuda que dá um
jeito nesse negócio para responder claro
enderson lá no meu canal tem o vídeo de
várias dúvidas assim eu vou te mandar o
link não adinta pra você conseguir pegar
todas as chances chegou e não tem
resposta para tudo bem mas a massa de
marvel obrigado eu terminar o vídeo aqui
eu já vou botar logo deixando aqui pra
carregar e vou lá está ele ouve que os
há muita coisa tecnologia de idade que
de várias coisas agora eu queria ver
você fazer um rap que eu quero ver se
fica fácil explicar povo assim as coisas
no rep
embora aí o desafio feito amanhã mesmo
vou estar no meu canal já que você me
desafiou desafia também foi tomada bala
mulher que desafia ficar um dia inteiro
sem internet nadinha de internet evito
andar aqui no meu canal como foi essa
experiência topa me arrependendo aceito
amanhã faça o desafio aí e aí dia 28 eu
mando esse vídeo pra você
beleza a lei e não passar o diretor
disse à internet
desafiado pelo canal do valo passar um
dia inteiro 24 horas sem internet vou
passar lá no canal dela tá então o
primeiro link na descrição é o link
o canal da luz escreve lá tem muita dica
de tecnologia e aí ficar eu acho que
toda a tecnologia ela tem que ser visto
pelo lado bom você olhar as coisas
imposto o avião é sensacional quando se
não ficar reclamando conectado de avião
ao espelho agora tá cheia de furinhos no
espelho que ela sempre está em especial
se olha para você pensa que é cravo aí
meu esposo está se vendo o cartão
negócio na sua casa a caneta ai meu deus
está falhando assim passa a ficar quente
na escola fazia se passar na mesma ficar
aqui botar no pescoço não ficar
reclamando que toda tecnologia é bom
para mim serve - a tomada de três pinos
tomada de três pinos
é o o o [__] que veio em forma de
tomada e chega nos hotel essa desgraça
tomar ganha 15 merda é essa o seu futuro
e outra que brown e as tomadas que têm
no tempo hotel são velhos o marido de
verdade essas aqui essa aqui é
tecnologia é isso aí muito obrigado a
assistir esse vídeo até aqui dois que
dia 28 ao vivo do canal da lupo 2014
internet ou passar eu vou contar como
foi a experiência lá então se inscreve
no primeiro link na descrição do vídeo
não esquece clicarem gostei que você
clicando aqui e gostei
os vídeos continuou indo pra você tá se
inscreve no canal para nunca perder um
vídeo novo comenta aqui embaixo qual é a
coisa mais impressionante pra você na
tecnologia tudo que você acha de mais
impressionante assim as coisas
tecnológico o que você acha mais
impressionante comenta aqui em baixo pra
mim tá
tamo junto é nós tamo junto
valeu